chocolate is the key ingredient in my
favorite sweet fast food dishes which at
their best are always irresistible
instant and utterly satisfying
so when you want an indulgent chocolate
hit my next recipe will be right up your
alley
malt chocolate doughnuts street food is
all about satisfying your cravings these
donuts are sweet sticky and absolutely
delicious
first off we're gonna make the dough
now
this dough takes a bit of time
but it's really exciting
i'm heating all of the milk with the
sugar
this yeast
easy to get hold of now when you make
fresh donuts
you need fresh yeast
adding some of the warm milk to the
yeast will activate it which will help
the dough to rise
just half
give that a quick whisk
the sugar's dissolved in the milk
the fresh yeast disintegrates instantly
set the yeast mixture to one side while
it does its job
to start the main dough mix i'm adding
half the butter to the remaining milk
that gives the dough a nice silkiness i
want it light
so melt the butter into the milk
flour
into a sieve that helps to make the
dough nice and smooth and you know when
you've got a smooth dough
it sort of rises evenly
add a pinch of salt and two egg yolks
pour in the warm milk and melted butter
don't start over mixing it
when you over mix
the dough of the doughnut it gets really
tight you're not gonna let it ariel
yeast in
nice and warm
i love that smell
now i'm looking for a sort of elasticy
texture just dropping off the spoon
nice flour the board
take the dough out
lovely
lightly sprinkle a touch more flour
and just pull it over and push in
every time you're sort of turning it
almost like you're turning the dough
into itself the dough should just sort
of relax
and it shouldn't be sticking to your
fingers now it's just nice and pliable
set that in a nice clean bowl
it will sprinkling
flour in there so as it starts to rise
it doesn't stick
cover that with thin film
leave the dough to rise in a warm place
for 60 to 90 minutes until it's doubled
in size this stage is called proving
now whilst that's proving get a panel
for the chocolate filling or ganache
pour 500 mils of double cream into a
saucepan and add honey
[Music]
bring the mixture to a gentle boil
[Music]
traditionally we've always put jam in
there but chocolate and donuts wow to
die for
add the cream
i give that a good mix
the butter elevates the ganache into a
really nice
shiny chocolate coat
look at that whoa
give it a really nice whisk
the whistling gives it that aerated
texture to ganache you're just
lightening the load a little bit
nice
chocolate filling done
put it in the fridge to cool then it's
time to gently roll out the dough
just let it roll naturally about a
centimeter and a half
in depth
slice
one
two
place them on to your tray
and let them rise again once the donors
have had 30 to 40 minutes to rise it's
time to shallow fry them in a pan filled
one third full with hot vegetable oil
risen but look they're sort of
like little pockets of
air right here we go
place these in nice and carefully
four maximum if there's too many in the
pan the oil will go cold and the donuts
will come out soggy
turn them over
beautiful
i gotta come out into some sugar mixed
with some malt powder
50 50.
how do you tell they're actually cooked
in the center
tap on top it should be hollow
in
and just sprinkle
the malt
and the sugar
shake off
the excess i get so excited every time i
make donuts
now
look at those beauties
these are delicious eating as they are
but the ganache is going to be the icing
on the cake
piping bag
peel the bag
over your hand
don't forget to pop the nozzle in
i want the texture
almost like a little liquid inside
so i'm going to pipe them in a little
bit warm hopefully with that burst of
magic
operation donut
lift up
the donut squeeze push in and fill
just to start seeing that chocolate
coming out
sit that back down
[Music]
nice
sit them on there
they've got a little bit heavier and we
all know why
nice
that one's got my name on it
that is amazing
[Music]
in great bacon as with all cooking
sometimes less is more
the easiest dishes look and taste
spectacular when they're done well
and it doesn't come any simpler or more
stylish than my next dish wonderful
baked cheesecake for me food always has
to be impressive but when it comes to
desserts
often you see spun sugar or wild
decorations remember simple
is always the most impressive this
cheesecake is so straightforward yet so
delicious
now cream cheese leave it out the fridge
for five or ten minutes
go nice and soft
trust me your arms will be thanking you
sugar in this cheesecake is
new york cheesecake because it's baked
so there's no base start creaming the
cheese and the sugar
spending the amount of time i do in the
states if there's one thing they know
how to do out there is the most amazing
impressive cheesecake rich delicious but
so simple
work the bowl
lift the bowl to your advantage
really whisk
whisk whisk whisk
lovely
nice and creamy now
get your
eggs add the eggs to the mixture bit by
bit doing it this way it's more
efficient
hey you're incorporating a lot of air
b the mixture doesn't separate
the last of your
egg lovely
of course you can use electric mixer but
why go to the gym we can just make a
cheesecake a day
a cheesecake a day
keep the bingo wings away
now a couple of tablespoons of flour
give it a whisk
stop something going lumpy
now i want to scent that cheesecake
i've got the freshness zest of the lemon
in there i want to sort of tart it up
even more fold in
some fresh raspberries
so just mix them through
be careful to crush them
then grease a cake tin with butter this
will ensure your cheesecake slides out
beautifully
get your mix
let that fall in
now take your cake tin and just
tap it
the mixture hits the bottom of the cake
tin the raspberries rise and you've got
raspberries at the top the middle and
the bottom it also stops all these
little pockets of air trapping
underneath the mixture in the cake tin
there's no holes
in the cheesecake
now into the oven 180 degrees for 35 to
40 minutes
[Music]
slightly souffled up
pull
off
that's the color i wanted
on top
and look at it
it's one of the simplest
yet the most stylish cheesecakes
anywhere
beautiful
[Music]
even if you got a super busy lifestyle
it doesn't mean missing out on delicious
desserts they just have to be simple to
make
when it comes to cooking at home
puddings should always be a pleasure and
never a chore and homemade puds are 100
guaranteed to impress
my next recipe has only two main
ingredients but simplicity doesn't mean
food can't taste out of this world
incredible griddle pineapple with spiced
caramel
if you're making a dessert for one or
two it's gonna be quick and easy this
sumptuous delicious griddle pineapple
fits the bill perfectly
pineapple
way of testing it's nice and ripe
the top of the leaves come out perfect
ready to go
always cut a pineapple with a serrated
edge knife
slice off the bottom turn it back over
and slice the top part
now
keep that
for later
look at the core
the center of the pineapple and slice
down directly in half
slice that in half
take each quarter
and slice them
smells incredible
lay down flat and just slice
that core off
so you've got this perfect
sort of boat of pineapple
slice underneath
but stop
as you get
right at the end
slicing around the skin will make the
pineapple easier to eat but leaving it
attached gives you more control as it
cooks
next heat a griddle pan as hot as you
can
start off
in the corner and push it down
so you really mark the pineapple
two minutes on each side
and then just
turn them
really nice color now look at that
beautiful
i'm gonna sprinkle them with a little
touch of sugar that's going to glaze
them
now
slice the top
take out these beautiful glazed
slices of pineapple
next up the spiced caramel
now start off with your pan
nice and hot
sprinkle
four tablespoons of sugar in there
just flatten
it then add the seeds from a fresh
vanilla pod
in
a small dusting of chinese fly spice
never stir caramel let it sort of bubble
and transform
here she goes now i've got the color i
want it that's the perfect color off
with the gas
in with the butter and then
a couple of tablespoons of cream
lovely and then give that a little whisk
add the rest of your cream
nice
and just
drip
that spicy caramel
over your pineapple
[Music]
wow
simple elegant and seriously impressive
griddle pineapple with spiced caramel a
delicious treat all to yourself that
tastes even better shared